Fossil fuels have got to go.
We must put an end to these
climate-destructive, loosely regulated,
dirty businesses
that are destroying the Earth.
We've done the math,
we have the data,
and we know that these dirty businesses
are making it increasingly
more uninhabitable on this planet.
But when those jobs go away,
there'll be green jobs, right?
Again, we've run the numbers,
we have the data
and we know that the more we invest
in a green economy,
the more jobs there’ll be:
[more] healthier, higher-paying jobs
in the future than there are today.
But here's the thing.
People eat bread, not data.
And when a corporation
shuts down a coal mine,
as happy as some of us may be
about cleaner air,
the reality is that people lose paychecks,
they lose pensions,
they lose jobs that they thought
were going to be there for their children.
Schools close, small businesses shutter,
and homes are lost.
Poverty sets in.
There are no green jobs
waiting for those folks.
Shutting down a coal mine,
a coal refinery
or most polluting facilities
can devastate a community and a family.
At the end of the day,
I'm not so much a tree hugger
as I am a people hugger.
And I don't really believe
in this dichotomy
of jobs versus the environment.
We can protect both.
But we're not going to get it right
if we just helicopter in
and tell people what's right.
That's where unions come in.
Unions for generations have been fighting
to protect workers' rights and justice.
I grew up hearing people speak
about justice all the time.
My mom started the first environmental
justice organization here in Detroit.
Yes, Donele Wilkins, Detroiters
Working for Environmental Justice.
(Applause)
She started the first environmental
justice organization
here in the city of Detroit,
and yet, I still didn't truly understand
the intricacies of workers
and the environmental movement
until I was sitting offstage,
listening to a heated back and forth
between a high-ranking member
of the United Mine Workers of America
and a panel of climate experts
that I had assembled
for the Coalition of Black Trade
Unionists's Annual Convention.
On this panel, I had Cecil Corbin-Mark,
the late Cecil Corbin-Mark,
deputy director of WE ACT,
an Environmental Justice Organization,
based out of Harlem;
Jackie Patterson,
the founder and director
of the Shirley Chisholm Legacy Project,
a climate justice resource hub;
and Donele Wilkins,
CEO of Green Door Initiative,
who also happens to be my mother.
(Applause)
I thought everything was going well.
I thought that regardless of politics,
we all kind of agreed that climate change
was a problem for human health,
for our families, for our homes.
So there I was, sitting in the first row,
Cecil was moderating,
and then this high-ranking leader
from the United Mine Workers of America
comes to the mic.
And shit got heated.
(Laughter)
Like, really bad.
I'm talking at this point,
I'm flushed red,
sweat is beading down my face,
and I'm thinking how best
to update my resume
because they're not going to let me
keep my job after this shit.
(Laughter)
I look to my boss and he has
this look on his face that says,
"Get your ass on stage."
That's a lot to say in the book,
but I promise you this look said a lot.
(Laughter)
When the panel ended, my boss
pulled me aside and he said,
"You need to fix this."
So I quickly secured a room
to have a private conversation
with the mineworkers and the panelists,
and we listened.
We heard the coal miners
talk about their desires,
their fears, their legacies,
this dignity in their work.
And we talked about the real reason
why the coal industry was dying,
which had more to do with profitability
than it did with activists or policy.
Coal is becoming more expensive
while the cost of renewable
energy is falling.
Investors are divesting from coal
because of its impact on the climate
and the risk associated
with climate change.
We all felt heard.
We felt understood.
The coal miners had opportunity
to separate the person
from the problem.
We talked about the history
of environmental justice
and its roots in the labor movement.
Since that day,
and the months and years following,
I started to see change
in the coal miners.
They, for a long time,
have been actively [in] opposition
to any types of climate policy.
But now they're open to exploring taxes
and emission standards
to regulate their industry.
And while they aren't exactly
where I would like them to be,
they have come a long way,
they've made progress.
Unions have a long history
of keeping the needs
and priorities of workers in their mind,
protecting workers rights
and fighting for justice.
In Memphis, 1968,
a union of sanitation workers
went on strike
after two African Americans
had been crushed
in a malfunctioning garbage truck.
That strike ended in April of 1968,
when the city of Memphis agreed
to recognize their union
and to meet the workers' demands.
In South Africa in 1985,
the Congress of South African
Trade Unionists
quickly became the strongest
and most powerful union in South Africa
by putting pressure on the apartheid
government through protests,
boycotts and strikes
that led to negotiations in 1990
and the end of apartheid in 1994.
And in Denmark,
when the country was transitioning
away from fossil fuels to wind energy,
the union 3F negotiated
with the government
and wind energy companies to secure jobs,
retraining programs and fair wages.
Those workers were equipped
to get employed
in this new and growing
wind energy sector.
Those workers were equipped.
You know,
the union movement is the only
multigenerational, multiethnic,
multiracial, multigender
movement in the world.
We're talking about tens
of millions of people
united around a singular set of ideas.
So it makes so much sense
that they're a part of this fight
for a just transition.
So how can we,
those of us that are in the climate fight,
properly work with unions?
It starts with deep listening
conversations,
like the ones we had
at CBTU's annual convention.
And workers and those who are pushing
for a green energy transition
need to hear each other out.
We need to hear each other's fears,
each other's desires,
each other's ideas for the future.
There needs to be
an education on both sides,
one that allows us to learn
about the livelihood of workers
and for all of us to learn
about the impact of the climate crisis.
Since that conversation
that I had at CBTU,
I started to actively invite
the coal miners to meetings
and to the conferences that I attend
discussing just transition.
My desire is for them to articulate
a path towards green jobs
before negative profitability and policies
decides the fate for them.
I want unions to secure federal dollars
to aid in this transition
to retrain their members.
I want them to realize
they don't have to choose
between making a living and living
in a safe and healthy environment.
They can have both.
Hell, they deserve both.
(Applause)
I want them to realize
that they can live in a community
that generates renewable energy,
where they don't have to speculate
what's in their water and their air.
A community where people
are valued over pollution.
I want them -- thank you.
(Laughs)
(Applause)
I want them to realize that this isn't
some distant utopic future,
but a reality that can be had
in a few short years.
If the US government can bail out banks
and the auto industry,
like they did in the financial
crisis of 2008,
surely they can bail out
the American worker.
(Applause)
But I have a feeling
that this isn't going to happen
without a concerted push from the unions.
To transition to a green-energy economy,
to protect our planet,
we're going to have to make
some tough changes.
But I'm a serial optimist,
and I believe we can make this change
without too much pain.
Thank you.
(Applause)